Oh God my name is welcome to I'm very
very excited today because because I'm
not gonna play just any games I'm gonna
play your games if you remember I
announced the competition where your
brothers should make RPG Maker games I
collected the highest rated ones and I'm
so so excited to play them alright
alright let's do this Peter pie and the
bromancing stone got my old outro in
there so you know it's an OG broker made
this love the avatar they use for me
that is actually how my body looks like
and my hair except my house doesn't look
like that it's way bigger nice yet I'm
ready Mirchi I'm ready to start
recording every day every day is like
this Bank yeah where did she go phone
call oh it's Ken Phoenix have you
checked youtube today
no I'm working on a new video typical
youtubers lying about working whether or
not and looking for Marcia
I can't find her anywhere I haven't seen
her but I called to tell you Dylan
hacked you what the ass I never said
that before but I like the expression
he's just so strong so much bet who made
this who made this game so are you Felix
you can defeat him but you may need
protection I'm all out of condoms not
that kind of protection
I'll chick meditates dresser I'll check
my dresser you a but a bottom the XX
extra long dong who the said that I
am the narrator nice to meet you pierce
the narrator I don't even want to know
what do you aim what the is this
game it's my BR where oh it's my outfit
my suit at Ted can you get it brofist
you
have a fist or a body for that matter oh
yeah right no problem here no
problem here no problem here I don't I
don't have a problem what can I say
every day is a new fresh start to go
straight back to bed
you quoted me there that's awesome this
is awesome so far I love this I love
playing you bros creations I'm so glad
this what that buck if you're watching
this I succeeded
no no that's how a Denis if you're
watching this I have succeeded my
channel ken was right I am NOT a little
girl I will not be bullied up the
internet I own your channel and Marcia
Chi oh god now my Tia she is now my
personal beyblade oh
cutie pie I am your God so deal with it
Dylan you look sexy as but haters
gonna hate ducks gonna crack well
written well written bro
and this Means War pewds town if you can
fight your way out of a situation don't
why not you'll die really
haha just kidding what what
evil garbage-can best game of course
I'll attack it
Felix was victorious philic is now bro
level 3 but that ass was that that was a
VR battle Dylan must be merging the
dimensions all right what's the plain
run for it
bad plan Plan B up and die
that's a good plan no it's not
why am i walking around outside naked oh
yeah my VR soon forgot I've done that
the jack that is Jack isn't it Jack I
need your help dealing the hacker
kidnapped Murcia and each in control of
my youtube channel
I wish added booties to me like smoothie
3 booty Smitty how the ass - I find
simple bear oh wait how'd it sucked you
never made cool good good Chuck Jack
Petey Park I have my own Park guys jack
just hangs around there all day selling
drugs
is that it sorry mark I gotta say how
that good friend your boats anymore
dragon boat god damn god I hate Edgard
alright mark that actually looks like
mark mark how do you bromance the stone
no I don't know what you're talking
about
jack told me to ask you marking moon
alright I won't have you want to
just stone what that mark first you
need flowers and chocolate got a can
mark that's passed and Lost Woods isn't
he yeah shut up
well I need to find a way to get past
Edgar I might have something useful for
you
he gave us beef jerky thanks mark
take the beef jerky Edgar take the
beef jerky again not me take the
bait Shack
alright what was it the lost wood it was
left hey Ken Mart
all right Ken might his head service
weekend
welcome to Ken mark have some chocolate
and flowers the can just bromancing
the customer Felix romancing Ken I could
kiss you I will never say those
words
please don't Ken would kiss me in a
heartbeat now if you excuse me I have a
date with a stone good luck and stay
toasty how could this possibly oh my god
I'm on the ceiling sponsor eagle what do
you have for me a crowbar shouldn't I be
an eagle bar no that's where Eagles get
drunk oh this is funny I like like it
makes me cringe but it's funny this is
thanks for the get sponsor you go now
what do I do with this crowbar
maybe I on the stone of course all right
stone I love you it's working I brought
you a box of chocolates harder faster
come on and flowers what's wrong pits I
just a stone I just a
stone now that is literate literature I
can't say it okay we're in the perilous
home spooky senpai notice me senpais
dylan the hacker has Martin he's trying
to merge the dimensions stop Dylan we
must before it's too late
traveled to the sewer we will waiting in
the darkness he is sent by Beryl joined
your quest killed the narrator
we will this barrel is following me now
okay so we have the barrel following us
I just don't know why oh okay we go in
the sewers Dylan I'm coming for you I
hope you didn't mean that lyric now I
did it
Yolo we're in the VR world this is
amazing I can't believe you bros made
this is one of the submissions oh my god
is that Dylan or Slenderman it's slender
in 2014 means all right we have magic
now to pee so it what's beyond
Slenderman best game
hey we kill Enderman with me how about
that wait what the
fabulous you know what's Lindy after we
deal with Dylan you can do tentacle porn
this is great guys we got barrels and
Slenderman a fabulous Slenderman oh here
we go that's Dylan and there's Marty at
what it's time to merge the world's
because I am a hundred percent
cold-blooded a wise man once said don't
worry tampons if you're a boy the hell
Felix but if you want to slam it out
facing my virtual forum Ultima Dylan
Jesus Christ now that is some fanfiction
I can get into okay let's pee on it hey
that was pretty easy
Matz it oh he's crying aw for Dylan
mites Aaron you're gonna my hair up you
did it Felix
and so we conclude our story with
Dylan's evil plant warded the hero saves
the princess and now we can go back to
making videos Slendy it's time to make
it your debit fabulous oh god no
oh it's so fun thank you so much for
making this game Freddie simmer it
simmering good job panty collector mm
this is kind of freaking me out
ooh dude that's a cool ass avatar man
why did I shave my beard
god damn it those kidnappers don't worry
Felix I am your guardian angel I'll
guide you through everything that is
exactly how I envisioned my guardian
angel I'm not gonna lie so what am I
doing here you are the chosen one the
one who must go on an important quest
and what is this quest you're talking
about you must collect all the female
panties from the kingdom of Ikea I've
done this all right that is something
that I was made for good luck Felix may
the painters be watching over you let's
see what that say great job you managed
to get outside there may be hope for you
after all Wow a sassy angel mmm look at
those curves such a beautiful rock what
is with these games and me with rocks oh
my god is that what I think it is you
found one Felix you really are the truth
I obtained panty all right you need to
be level two to proceed how do I get
level two you just have to pull my
finger Oh
should I do it breast I'll pull the
finger hmm can you smell it
you leveled up best game don't worry
lady I'll teach him a lesson
works trying to steal Marcia's panties
only I can steal Marcia's panties you
orcs Jesus my name is Felix
Felix from the why do I give my I say
the dumbest voice I'm sorry Felix from
the kingdom of Ikea and what is your
name sexy lady
what that man another painting I
don't know hey man I got a gift I got
again how are you wanna have sex all
right someone's very young babies yeah
well it's realistic at least I just
thought I knew it
you truly are the chosen one no thank
you
next time on Dragon Ball Z where were
you when it happened so good
the ending was really egg top I can't
see who made the game but thank you this
wonderful person for making this game
you're awesome
really appreciate it let's check out the
next game
Papa boots all right what in here and
here I am the number one youtuber the
reaches baby cam the most handsome dude
in the whole world you first really
captured my personality so modestly in
this one I appreciate that thank you I
feels so empty oh wow it really is
realistic let's go and see Maria her
wisdom shall guide me in my times of
need
I love the outfit I have it's so good
baby
ok stop talking like this you're not
even Japanese yeah cool when I have sex
why is that an option she exploded all
right yeah cool what have sex
hi oh my god that actually worked
don't tell my why are you crying
because you said I was only a side
to Marcia maybe if we have sex
I'll change my mind really okay then
this is not how you treat women I do not
support let's go this way
might see us the other way but I want to
go there well you can't why not oh my
god just turn around and keep playing
the damn game knowledge you know what I
appreciate more than all these cars and
money knowledge what she's in here maybe
she went out wait
there's a letter on the table boots oh
hey kidnap your girlfriend because you
suck because I hate you come and find me
if you dare or kill yourself like hey
No
you don't worry I'll come
and get you do the food scape I love
Malcolm isn't it oh my god alright let's
start up the computer and find this
this is where I make videos of course
what the hell what is happening
stop leave their Dylan no it can't be
looks like I got you good this time and
we're playing on the log I knew that if
mal can kidnap your girlfriend you would
panic that you went right wherever you
need to go and you fell right into my
trap
the world will know for food if I really
it's all will know how uncreated and how
much of a loser you are
and after this humiliation I will oh
yeah how are you gonna do this absorb me
with your lips I will hack you to death
oh no this can't be good are we fighting
now wait the the matrix backwards what
is this place welcome to my virtual hell
there's no way you can get to me except
if you crack my three uncrackable
passwords that is yeah we'll see about
that
I have we gotta hack the computers roses
are red violets are blue vodka cost less
than dinner for two access granted
no these can't be what is love what it's
like shrek is love access granted
common for you Dillon but don't get your
hopes too high my virtual faces are
still there
last one talk dirty to me ya know what
have you done it's over Delian I win
what am I gonna do
fight smack his ass maybe we can talk
this through right slap him roast him
spank him finish him these are all such
great options where do I begin
roast him Dylan the hacker more like
Dylan the wanker to finish him time to
make sure you won't pose any further
threat no wait I can explain myself
today Dylan you Creston Han I don't
really hate you I just troll I just do
this for views please spare me nice
try oh man I am roof
that's what you get did I just beat the
out of him
oh the virtue morality is collapsing I
can't die not like this um well goddamn
it I don't have a choice I will rescue
Marcia and save my steps let's do this
oh man all right let's do it it's
PewDiePie yeah you came in to be
finished because you suck because you is
only working for it the money
hey because I hate you take the left
door and you will keep all yourself so
nice yeah will they take the right door
and you will find mazey but your subs
will be lost forever no how can you be
so cruel
make your choice B DB its people
nevermind well I got a pic Mart say
otherwise I'll be dead
Mattia Felix you're finally here that's
it are you okay I waited for a few hours
in this creepy kid with the weird voice
came up I was scared but I knew you
would come for me as a cliche as it
sounds
yeah the dev is kind of lacking
imagination yeah but I thought you would
abandon me I thought you were selfish
doing things only for the money I may
have lost all my subs Malcolm but I kept
my dignity what about you we have to be
honest with you there never was a
program what yes Dylan and I made that
up just to show you who you really were
but we were rude I'm Sami better go now
mom is calling me for dinner all's well
that ends well
yep I guess so
PTP and cutie pie we're finally able to
resume their peaceful lives as YouTube's
no hater came to harm them and they had
fun together with their communities for
ever and ever the end made by Zyra
thanks for everything periods keep doing
whatever you want because that's what we
like oh that's a sweet I have three more
games but I think this videos gonna run
on for too long so I think I'll do a
part two with us thank you so much for
making these games it really means a lot
to me that you bros make something
really cool and all the hours you spend
into this that's amazing I'm so thankful
that I have such cool fans that create
cool stuff like this and I these are my
favorite types of videos to make feel
like we're making a video together and I
hope you both enjoyed watching this as
well thanks for being such cool bros
alright I'm I'm so I don't want to say
privilege cuz that'll give you guys too
much you're not that great but
I'm so happy I got I got cool breasts
like that that's awesome thank you so
much for watching leave a like view
enjoyed and I'll see you in the next
video tomorrow as always stay awesome
breasts it was so cute
you guys are my main motivation you guys
are my main motivation luxurious well
still are the percents I can barely pull
this is my good old set up my apartment
it's really a way to way to show the
apartment hey guys this is my apartment
luxurious for my standard at least I can
barely afford to pay the rent oh my god